[Music]
officials must pursue this seriously
it's an important matter
if there are some hands behind us and
some persons or groups are involved this
is a big and unforgivable crime
[Music]
it was PE class but no one showed up
when we went to the hall we smelled
something like perfume
my stomach burned and I was blacking out
I
the students all felt the same symptoms
as me they had coughs some of them said
their eyes burned and most of them were
scared
[Music]
I apologize for what's happening and
their parents got worried we are waiting
to receive the results of tests we
totally understand parents concerns and
we seriously follow the issue we have
formed emergency committees within the
education Ministry
[Music]
foreign